and from this project lead I learned the
principle that you should share good
news always in writing but bad news only
verbally right so good news in writing
bad news when you did something wrong
only verbally and the reason for that is
that if you did something great you can
write about this then maybe your team
lead other members of your team receive
this as an email for instance they can
potentially forward it around forward it
to other people in the organization
though the other way around this is what
you might avoid when you actually did
something wrong when you did a mistake F
when you did an error so yes be open and
honest about it but try to do this
verbally in person or on the phone but
do not put this information in an email